on n'a pas trop le choix
on fait notre course à saint-cloud
normalement fait 5 à 6000 personnes sur
site
donc on a vu très rapidement qu'on
n'allait pas pouvoir la faire
entièrement sur site
on est passé tout de suite en un mode
mixte à la fois connecté et sur site
et puis au début septembre lorsqu'on a
vu que les choses par les conditions
sanitaires se compliquer on a passé sur
un mode entièrement connectée connectés
ça veut dire que sur place il y avait
juste en fait une équipe de tournage
avec quelques animations les personnes
qui allaient monter sur le podium et on
a rare transcrit un événement pour des
personnes qui étaient qui courait en
fait partout en france et même à
l'étranger de tous nos événements ont
été annulés
il faut savoir qu'à peu près 200
événements sont faits pour l'association
par des par des bénévoles des personnes
extérieures
on a aussi un deuxième événement qui
s'appelle le rallye du coeur nous ce
sont des voitures de collection ou des
voitures de sport qui se réunissent à
versailles et avec normalement un enfant
avec sa famille dans les voitures donc
cette année impossible de mettre des
enfants dans les voitures
donc on a fait un parrainage entre des
pilotes et des enfants
on a peu été touchée dans l'association
par des par des personnes qui ont le
quotid ou alors ils l'ont eue mais pas
de manière très très grave
ça en fait un pacte et l'association en
tant que tel parce qu'on a il a fallu
qu'on se réorganise complètement du jour
au lendemain on a été en télétravail
donc voilà on a bien connu les réunions
en visio et le suivi de tout ce qu'on
fait en visio donc c'était comment
est-ce qu'on garde le contact entre nous
mais comment aussi on garde le contact
avec nos partenaires avec les familles
avec les hôpitaux
donc voilà ça a été comment est-ce qu'on
recrée du contact à distance